si j'écoute bruno si à chaque fois qu'on
est battu on n'a plus le droit de se
présenter je te rappelles tu as été
battu à la présidence de l'ump
ce n'est pas ce que je dis nicolas c je
dis sincèrement j'en suis heureux pour
moi et désolé pour toi dis simplement là
peu avant la candidature de 2012 qui
avait dit si je la remets tu m'as temps
je ne reviendrai pas on peut lever venez
les mots ont un sens je vais venir s'y
est battu c'est est rédhibitoire
françois mitterrand n'aurait jamais été
président de la république de foix et
jacques chirac non plus on se serait
passé de deux grandes personnalités
commencent d'abord par essayer d'être
élu tu verras que c'est très difficile
ensuite je vais vous dire les choses ici
le nicolas lozzi amplement que jacques
chirac et je bosse de mitterrand n'ont
pas été battus comme président sortant
ils ont été battus comme candidat ils
ont été battus l'ex keeper vivait
apparemment de choses et je te souhaite
d'ailleurs que ça t'arrive
parce que c'est la défaite qui fait
apprendre chose comprendre des choses et
faire évoluer une personnalité c'est
comme sur les lacs nous femmes a pour
son nikon a que j'ai tiré la leçon
beaucoup de notre et les fêtes
l'ump en 2014